aujourd'hui tous les employés de la
petite cité de tarpon springs sont
invités à un barbecue par madame le
maire elle ne doit pas son élection à
ses largesses mais plutôt à son mariage
car la blonde beverly a eu la bonne idée
d'épouser un grec figure historique de
cette communauté
incontournable de la ville georges
beliris est né ici en floride
il n'y a pas loin de 80 ans que cet
ancien capitaine de navire a vécu toute
sa vie du commerce de l'eponge l'eponge
naturel bien sûr celle qui vient du fond
des mers
les grecs aux états unis sont reconnues
d'ailleurs il ya une petite histoire
maroc à peine ouvre-t-il une boutique de
hot dogs au rez de chaussée d'un
immeuble et hop ils sont déjà
propriétaires de l'immeuble solaire ils
sont très opiniâtre et dure au travail
d'un autre côté l'histoire de tarkan
spring est assez différente
une romance une histoire d'amour avec
les américains c'est une grande histoire
d'amour grâce au mythe du farouche
pêcheurs d'éponger les touristes disent
on est en grèce on est en amérique et on
va en grèce sans passeport en allant
tarp en sprint
c'est l'impression se fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les quais de tarpon springs une des plus
grandes attractions de la floride
tarpon springs capitale mondiale de
lépanges
[Musique]
bon on vous la corde cela ressemble un
peu à un disneyland anémique avec éponge
à gogo et foires en soule acquis
[Musique]
le quai des docks lui est réservé à la
dizaine de bateaux de pêcheurs des ponge
encore en activité et ce jour là
solon et dimitra un couple de plongeurs
professionnels revenait de campagne de
pêche trois semaines dans les eaux
verdâtres du golfe du mexique
à quelques dizaines de milles au large
en surveillant la météo car les ouragans
menace dès le début de l'automne
il a au rideau rayspan manège on est en
mer de nombreux jours on travaille dur
on rentre au port et on essaie de vendre
nos éponge le plus vite possible pour
repartir à nouveau si le temps le permet
selon lui a débuté ce métier en grèce
encore adolescent avant d'émigrer et de
travailler comme peintre en bâtiment aux
états unis pendant 30 ans à un moment
donné de ma vie j'ai décidé de fabriquer
un bateau pour aller à la pêche aux
épaules un jour aimé ça depuis que je
suis gamin respect pour cadac ici en
amérique c'est la même chose quand je
vois la mer pour toi c'est la même chose
que tu travailles en grèce ou en
amérique la mer et par air sol on n'a
fait que suivre ses ancêtres
quand il y à 100 ans exactement on a
découvert des fils en dépend ici les
plongeurs grecs sont venus vendre leurs
talents méditerranée et golfe du mexique
sont deux des rares endroits au monde où
les fonds sont tapissés des ponts
exploitables
[Musique]
des centaines de familles ont migré dans
le petit port de floride et les grecs se
sont implantés durablement au fil des
générations
participant à la prospérité de tarpon
springs
[Musique]
le coup de fil est arrivé hier
nikita et les autres sont coincés dans
une marina 1 200 kilomètres au nord de
tarbes en sprint
le vent mauvais les a rabattu sur la
côte mais il possède de la marchandise à
vendre
[Musique]
de quoi remplir le vieux camion de
michael koutouzis marchand international
des ponge depuis plus de 30 ans
ça va petit nicolas qui nous apporte de
bonnes nouvelles
dita des bonnes nouvelles les bonnes
nouvelles bonnes nouvelles que des
bonnes nouvelles aux les remarques sont
belles les noirs celles là sont plus
belle encore mike tu crois qu'il existe
un capitaine qui avoue avoir de la
cochonnerie comme cargaison d ponge
aulas michael qui doit juger de la
qualité en un clin d'oeil avant de
proposer ses prix acheteurs et vendeurs
se connaissent depuis des décennies un
manager
il aime traiter les affaires de la même
façon en grec et à la grecque
un pêcheur des ponts je ne vois jamais
avoir confiance en lui sont braves
ils sont vaillants mais s'ils peuvent
voler ils le feront
regarde par exemple cette éponge là elle
n'aurait pas dû être là et si tu leur
demande pourquoi ils l'ont mise dans le
lot ils te diront que c'est une erreur
erreur erreur qu'un jour mais toujours
dans le même sens jamais de risque de
trouver une bonne éponge dans un mauvais
loin
moi oui c'est vrai on n'a jamais fait le
contraire mettre des bonnes éponge dans
un mauvais lot nous autres pêcheurs nous
sommes un peu gourmand nous testons le
marchand pour lui casser les reins mais
lui de son côté s'il a l'occasion il
nous donne un bon coup de sabot pour
nous mettre à terre nikitas cambourakis
le plongeur migrants de la bande
car si ses deux compères habite aux
états unis lui navigue entre l'ancien et
le nouveau continent depuis 1974 au gré
des opportunités à la recherche du
meilleur profit je suis un homme qui
lutte
je suis un pécheur des ponge le driver
comme on élit si il dit au palais mois
mais l'une l'âge allait commencer et en
juin en grèce dès l'âge de 13 ans
jusqu'à aujourd'hui arrivé à 63 ans
je n'ai pas cessé de lutter j'ai subi de
nombreux accidents dans ce boulot j'ai
même manqué rester une fois j'ai dû
rester 35 jours en caisson de
décompression à l'hôpital j'étais devenu
paralytique
et puis je suis revenu à la vie ne dites
pas à ces quatre hommes qu'ils sont
grecs n'ont en fait ils sont originaires
de kalymnos le centre du monde dans le
microcosme de l'époque michael qui a
rencontré des plongeurs sur tous les
continents ne jure que par les habitants
de son île d'origine
c'est peut-être souvent dire cela mais
de tout temps les meilleurs plongeurs
ont été les cas les menottes
[Musique]
les autres il avait aussi de bons
plongeurs mais ils ont arrêté d'exercer
cette activité les 95% des pêcheurs des
points restant ce sont des gens de
caliméro aînée d'à peine 2 de
sainte-catherine et kalemie
[Musique]
le titre prestigieux de capital de
l'eponge tarpon springs doit peut-être
le partager avec kalymnos
[Musique]
cette île du dodécanèse plus tôt - clamé
haut et fort son titre de capitale
historique
[Musique]
et malgré la mystérieuse maladie qui
ravagea l'animal en 1986 et diminue à la
production ces vingt dernières années
l'eponge est loin d'avoir complètement
disparu des eaux grecques
il ya des gens dans la rue adam exposait
ses pêcheurs ont bourlingué près de deux
mois dans toute la mer egée et leurs 300
kilos dé ponge 16 sur la place publique
depuis l'antiquité jusqu'à aujourd'hui
ça reste la capitale mondiale des babas
kalymnos reste à la première place on
spring produit des éponges cuba aussi
les bahamas et les planches
méditerranéen reste le meilleur c'est
ici qu'a démarré tout l'activité
c'est ici que commence toute l'histoire
dans les pages
coca cola
on a quitté nikita en floride et nous
voilà en grèce avec anastasio son cousin
et anthony son frère
tous des cambourakis tous plongeurs
depuis l'adolescence comme s'il n'essaie
avec la carte des fonds de méditerranée
imprimé dans la tête c'est tout à
l'heure de se souvenir
comme dans chaque métier il y a une
expérience une intuition la pensée où
aller et où retourner là où l'année
précédente encore l'année d'avant on
avait laissé de la loi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
seuls quatre espèces dépenses sont
exploitables
ici on trouve surtout des caps add in
ces grosses taches noires qui se vendent
à bon prix car les pêches de
méditerranée reste la plus cotée pas
n'importe laquelle elles se ressemblent
toutes
mais seul un petit pourcentage de celles
ci ont une valeur commerciale
[Musique]
celui qui commença du mal les premières
fois et tu apprends vite à voir les
différences entre les punchs sauvage et
l'eponge commercialise à l'abonné pont
jeunes noirceur différentes
elle est plus douce plus onctueuse qui
le sont par les sensations humaines et
aux abattoirs et aux nerfs d'acier c'est
un délice
les plongeurs de kalymnos travail tôt
compresseur même si ce n'est pas
vraiment légal une technique qui leur
permet de récolter pendant quatre à cinq
heures sans ressortir j'ai le plongeur
au bout et je pêche
je surveille pour cent mais le temps
parce qu'il ya la vie dans mon jeu on
doit faire attention à tout surveillez
le plongeur trio la machine regardez
autour s'il n'y a pas d'autres bateaux
qui s'approche faut avoir des yeux
partout des heures au fond de l'eau mais
le travail ne s'arrête pas là l'eponge
est un animal rempli de roche de
végétaux et de petits coquillages
c'est son squelette nettoyer purifier
qui se vendra ensuite pour ce faire les
plongeurs vont passer des heures sur le
pont pour préparer les éponges
quand tu la sors de l'eau l'épongé noir
labat et elle deviendra blanche tu dois
la piétiner pour que le laisse en haye
pour qu'elles blanchisse et tu dois la
race et plusieurs fois l'eau de mer on
voit tout de suite que c'est une bonne
éponge
demain elle sera blanche c'est le plus
dur métier du monde
tu mets ta vie en danger tu travailles
loin de chez toi tu ne te lave pas
beaucoup tu es loin de tes enfants de
tes petits enfants je vais loin de tout
et pourtant anastasio a lui aussi tenté
sa chance aux états unis en amérique on
m'a chassé c'est pour cela que je de
plusieurs autres parce que j'étais
migrants clandestins entré comme
touriste qui suis restée trois ans et
qu'est ce que vous êtes
ils m'ont attrapé ils m'ont ligoté avec
des menottes pieds et mains liés
provient
si les kalymnos ne pêche plus qu'une
petite partie des éponges dans le monde
il reste les experts par qui transite la
majorité de la production pas notre
aramis dirige un des dix ateliers des
ponts existants un kalymnos ils achètent
de l'eponge dans le monde entier
la traite l'a blanchi dans des bains
d'acide et surtout la coupe forcément à
la main
cela reste le travail du patron car
suivant la découpe on peut gaspiller de
la matière première
j'ai pris une grande éponge avec une
forme bizarre et qui est difficile à
couper la coupe en différents morceaux
de plus petite taille
j'essaie de faire les morceaux qu'ils
soient bien sans trop de défauts ni trop
haut ni déchirure chaque éponge à sa
personnalité c'est comme les autres il
n'y en a jamais de pareils nous dans le
commerce on a besoin des punchs
standardisée de la même taille de la
même quel but
parce que éponge souvent à la pièce et
chaque client demande une forme et un
gabarit précis
les synthétiques n'ont pas chassé les
naturelles les éponges pour le bain se
vante encore beaucoup en europe et au
japon
mais il existe aussi des centaines d'
utilisation différente dans l'industrie
le traitement de la porcelaine ou les
travaux de peinture
cette île rocailleuse en diable fut
longtemps la plus riche du dodécanèse
grâce au courage des hommes puisant leur
gagne pain dans les abysses littérature
grecque et peinture locales ont nourri
leur inspiration dans cet univers
mythologique
ces hommes en qui sait conserver le
caractère eplique très pure de la grèce
antique ont pour métier de plonger dans
les profondeurs de la mer lesté d'une
simple pierre pour tout attirail et dia
h et les éponges au fonds sous marins
[Musique]
un pagne autour des reins un saut
bricoler avec un fond de verre
rudimentaire même pour les années 60
[Musique]
et souvent les hommes partaient pour des
campagnes de pêche longue de sept mois
des journées entières dans les
profondeurs harnachés d'antiques
scaphandre à peine digne d'un album de
tintin
sans se soucier nullement des risques
dramatique de la décompression dans
chaque campagne de pêche il y à 3 à 4 %
de cas mortels il y a huit ou dix pour
cent de paralysie
les femmes en noir porte le deuil des
sommes que les profondeurs sous-marines
le remplir et si ce n'était le soleil
éclatant du dodécanèse on se croirait
dans l'île de sein
[Musique]
partir revenir kalymnos la floride
voici le destin des hommes d'ici
[Musique]
oh
tarpon springs ressemble un second
kalymnos peut-être plus profondément que
ne le laisse deviner ses boutiques et
bibelots et la cité américaine n'a de
cesse de dépasser son modèle faire plus
beau plus riche plus religieux aussi que
kalymnos
[Musique]
son pop orthodoxe par exemple vient
directement de l'île grecque
[Musique]
mais ici la messe se partage entre
langue grecque et anglaise pour ne pas
léser les descendants de la troisième ou
quatrième génération
les gens viennent beaucoup à l'église
nous avons beaucoup de gens pieux
tu as vu le monde qui lie à l'intérieur
c'est comme ça chaque dimanche on
célèbre pas comme à qu'elle va la hausse
de la même façon avec des tonneaux
dynamique derrière la porte
tu vois le marbre est cassé c'est de la
dynamite qui a explosé
ainsi il fallait aller voir derrière le
quai pour touristes
derrière les apparences pour découvrir
l'âme de tahar pons prise
les petits bars d'athènes street
ce pourquoi les immigrés comme les
quitta le pêcheur migrants se sentent
bien ici
ce qu'a fait on se sent un calice parce
que presque tout le monde ici c'est
interdit aux autres de temps en temps un
mec de 6 me vient mais des fois on
accepte dans notre banc défaut non je
plaisante on est tous bien ensemble ici
comme si on se trouvait en plein d'ondés
caennaise nikita ne s'arrête jamais de
travailler lorsqu'il vient en floride
[Musique]
à son image sa famille est un peu
partagé une fille mariée à new york deux
enfants installés à kalymnos sa famille
c'est plutôt le monde de l'eponge à
peine pose-t-il pied-à-terre que le
voile a embauché dans l'atelier de
michael koutouzis je n'ai jamais dit du
mal de mon métier
jamais jamais jamais plus je trouve des
éponges plus jeunes on cherche
je n'ai jamais couru après large je veux
juste faire ce travail car si j'avais un
peu de cervelle
j'aurais aussi de l'argent rami les
mensonges tout cela de dire tu n'as
jamais mais l'argent ce qui ne file pas
son salaire tu verras c'est court pas
après l'argent
[Musique]
installé pendant plus de 30 ans à
chicago mickaël vient d'ouvrir son
atelier tarpon springs mais depuis le 11
septembre 2001 ses nombreux voyages
d'affaires dans le monde entier ont paru
suspecte aux autorités difficile pour un
étranger de circuler librement
alors qu'il a dû prendre un passeport
américain
à contrecoeur grec et en deuxième lieu
tu es amérique jamais je ne viens jamais
vraiment américain simplement tu dis
merci à ce pays qui étaient accueillis
quitte à donner la possibilité d'exercer
son métier gagner ton pain et de faire
vivre sa famille
dimitra la plongeuse a fait un peu le
chemin à l'envers
elle est née et avec eux dans le nord
des états unis
mais elle venait passer ses étés de
jeunesse ici comme nombre de grecs
américains attirés par la mer et le
retour aux racines
ça vient peut-être de mon enfance quand
je venais à tarpon springs j'étais folle
des éponges comme les télécabines iott
[Musique]
et puis j'ai persévéré parce que
j'aimais la plongée c'est important de
connaître l'histoire de ces hommes qui
ont exploité le même océan que nous il
ramassait les mêmes éponge
c'est mon histoire et c'est ma culture
son histoire d'amour avec selon
symbolise cette union de deux villes
jumelles au delà de l'océan
car à défaut de vivre sur leur terre
natale
ces immigrants ont reproduit en terre
d'amérique la vie de leur petite île des
moyens et n'ont jamais cessé les allers
retours
[Musique]
mr oui il ya pas mal de gens qui vont et
viennent entre les deux il y en a qui
viennent travailler ici retourne là bas
quelques mois et reviennent il y en a
d'autres qui repartent définitivement à
kalymnos c'est dans leur sang cali
mignotte le désir de retourner en
arrière
je ne sais pas pour les autres
on ressent très fort le besoin de
retourner à nos origines
[Musique]
dans les histoires grecque il ne faut
jamais totalement oublié la mythologie
comme ulysse les cas limites subissent
les pires épreuves sur les mers du globe
en caressant le rêve de rentrer un jour
chez eux
[Musique]